all right so gonna go through three
peaches we're going to gather together
what we looked at yesterday which was
tangent goal and today we just very very
briefly looked at the core I'm not going
to get a special ones down we just want
to get the general that'd be enough okay
so on an ellipse for the tangent at
normal let's get down with the Cartesian
form and the parametric form
okay fact I might do the parametric work
first so I hope you remember yesterday
you're going to get this kind of shape
on the left hand side expose it
figure they must be X Y same thing on me
and that's equal to one right now by the
way as I go through this board you will
start to see why we put it into this
awkward it's not general form it's not
slow great slope intercept form is no
that beautiful it's a form that makes
all the parallels between the other
forms is used to see what was the what
was the Cartesian form on this equation
yeah we've got this on the board right
if you've got X x1 on a plus
where it was one as well so that's nice
nd not too complicated okay now pause
before we move on to the normal if you
were to imagine this saves your time but
for a hyperbola they're going to be two
differences number one when you see
pluses you are going to expect because
the hyperbola - idea you're going to
expect minus signs
wherever you see pluses right and
secondly for these this cos theta sine
theta plus theta and sine theta are kind
of irrelevant to the hyperbola right do
you remember what would the parametric
close for them you're going to get a
second enough B tan theta so number one
we're gonna flip the signs number two
we're gonna substitute out different
parametric forms in there okay so you're
grading is going to be X say clean up on
a and that's the same but sweeter out
there then there's a minus sign it's
gonna be white Anthea
that's the only difference I said me now
being that the Cartesian form doesn't
even rely on this parameter that we
introduce right the one difference
between the tangent of an ellipse and
the tangent of a hyperbola is just the
mighty Sun that's that's a woman's
changed so you get X X 1 y squared minus
y
okay do you see parallels right now the
normal because it's a normal one you get
negative reciprocals in there it's a
little bit Messier okay you've got this
guy right you've got that cause bigger
and the a they're switching switching
around you've got the B Y on side via
also switching around and then you've
got a minus in the middle that just came
from the algebra and we double check
that we've looked at it and that's what
you can do on the right hand side again
it's not as neat as the tangent I
believe we get a squared minus baseman
on the backhand side okay now similarly
there is a Cartesian form right and
again there's a very similar parallel
we're gonna get I think instead of adds
the x squared and X on x1 so you just
confirm that in your notes I can look at
the things that have changed and the
things that have stayed for the same
right I'm you're getting the reciprocal
of a step this way right this is gonna
then be on guessing he's spent one on y1
equals and still a squid administrator
okay and of course if we wanted to we
could verify that we had remembered this
right we hadn't gone upside down which
way roll by just taking the um Patrick
triples and putting it in there if you
put them in there you should get this
form might you remember we did that for
the table
all right good now fig hi we're now
going to go from ellipse to hyperbola so
I'm switching two things I'm going to
switch the parametric forms from Santa
Claus to second ten and then I'm also
got to switch around the sides okay so
here's the first for evidence okay and
now I just need to fit my signs around
they were both - in the first case right
so now they're going to be plus and then
thankfully personally because the
Cartesian form has nothing to do with
the parameter all the changes here is
done science very good so where I have
ways
okay
now last one for the sake of brevity I'm
just going to use this form okay that's
the shortest form you can possibly get
it into because you know there's two
angles to do it so let's just jot that
down in here in our table for the sake
of fitness it's all about this
although sorry just checking
just checking these up
correct exactly as you go down here you
increase in what you decrease in common
this commonality tangents come up all
the time if I'd been more that's
guarantee you will mean a tangent in
some form on the clinics and normal
sometimes comes up a chord really comes
up and when it does they kind of guide
you through it right they will show you
okay is this point with this point prove
that blah blah blah blah right and often
when you've got that result in part one
then it's like well even if I'm mucked
up the address I couldn't get it I can
still move on to it's that kind of
scenario okay okay now what changes and
the answer is some size and also some of
the packaging forms right so it's going
to sign a cause I'm going to get I guess
yes it is actually no sorry I think
about because you'll see why in a second
I've got two fractions here the end up
changing but because it's a minus sign
here that's the one that I changed and
what the least pain is possible I think
so I've got X minus na equals nice
re-erect ik
and then I've got now - side changes
there so that's just could be on a and
then the angle ends up staying the same
he really really knows but of course
that means a time line remember to be
honest I think the tender in the normal
fairly straightforward and the cord is
the hardest one which is why like I said
number one comes up the least frequently
and number two when it does it generally
will provide us as a result and say I
can prove it
Paulo maybe that's worth two months I
think there's a bit of work and then
part two I can use this now and show me
something about this because it's yeah
now you can fuse as you want you